elle les migrants sont ils une chance
sont ils un défi pendant près de deux
heures les intervenants ont débattu sur
ces problématiques dans l'espace
paroissiale du cap saint jacques près de
70 personnes étaient présentes pour
écouter notamment le témoignage une
migrants arrivés en france il ya
plusieurs mois
également présents pour l'occasion l'ex
député maire de versailles etienne pinte
l'actuel président du conseil national
des politiques de lutte contre la
pauvreté a rappelé le devoir historique
de la france face aux mouvements
migratoires actuelles la france pays des
droits de l'homme et des citoyens le
pays des libertés qui a toujours été
capture une image en quelque sorte
d'accueil de l'étranger de celui qui
réfugiés de celui qui est expulsé de
celui qui est en souffrance eh bien nous
devons répondre à cette tradition et
nous avons les moyens
le pays l'un des plus riches du monde 5e
ou 6e devancé en termes de chiffres par
l'allemagne à la suède l'italie ou
encore la grèce la france est loin
d'être le pays européen le plus
accueillant pour les migrants pourtant
les crispations sont nombreuses sur le
sujet en témoigne par exemple la récente
polémique sur l'accueil d'une centaine
de personnes à maurepas
il est quelque part un peu pratique le
million la crise c'est la faute du
migrant le système social en difficulté
c'est la faute du migrant le chômage
c'est la faute du migrant donc je pense
qu'il ya quelque part on a chargé de
tous les maux et aujourd'hui on a un
regard sur le migrant qui est
extraordinairement chargé on lui en veut
d'une certaine manière cette réunion
autour des migrants se tenait alors que
selon les derniers sondages près de six
français sur dix sont opposés à
l'accueil de personnes supplémentaires
sur le sol hexagonal